lampedusa is a small Italian island of
about 6 500 residents yesterday the
population of lampedusa more than
doubled as more than seven thousand
illegal immigrants from Africa arrived
on the island on more than 100 different
migrant boats
human traffickers took advantage of calm
seas yesterday to increase the number of
Migrant boats but this situation is
nothing unusual it is nothing new
hundreds often thousands of foreigners
illegally land at lampedusa every single
day and they have for well over a decade
well over a decade at which point
they're processed by the government of
Italy and generally given easy entry
into Europe laws be damned this was the
subject of Douglas Murray's excellent
book The Strange death of Europe
he published that book six years ago and
in the six years since he wrote that
urgent analysis of immigration the
situation has only gotten worse
drastically worse which is precisely
what liberal politicians in Rome and
Brussels and throughout the West want
according to them this Mass illegal
migration is not a political problem
but a solution
more votes for the liberal parties more
social friction less traditional Society
but it's not merely a tactic of spite
this is a logical conclusion of liberal
ideology which denies the distinction
between nations and cultures and peoples
we're all just kind of citizens of the
world man Kumbaya there's no such thing
as borders man
the liberal Europeans don't see any
distinction between themselves and
people beyond their borders
but the people beyond their borders do
European nations and economies and
customs
are much more pleasant than the sort
found in Africa and the Middle East and
elsewhere
so African migrants are invading
supposedly Sovereign Nations to the tune
of thousands per day
and the Europeans all these years after
the problem began continue to do nothing
to stop it because a liberal as Robert
Frost observed is a Man Too broad-minded
to take his own side in a quarrel
so the borders and the cultures and the
Nations collapse not through homicide by
foreigners but through a strange
civilizational suicide I'm Michael
nolsis the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show a man just
crashed a fashion show Runway wearing a
trash bag and he made it pretty far no
one noticed that he was an intruder and
not wearing high fashion we'll get to
that very important story in a second
first though speaking of foreigners
I intend to keep this segment on YouTube
so I'll try to watch my language a
little bit
the American transvestite who's
volunteering to be the spokesman for the
Ukraine military is now threatening
anybody who is in any way critical of
Ukraine's actions in this war
Russia hates truth that their obsessive
focus on a Ukrainian volunteer
simply allowing the light of the
Ukrainian nation's honesty to shine
brightly
next week the teeth of the Russian
Devils will Nash ever harder and the
Rabid mouths will foam in uncontrollable
frenzy as the world will see a favorite
Kremlin propagandist pay for their
crimes and this puppet of Putin is only
the first Russia's war criminal
propagandist will all be hunted down and
Justice will be served as we in Ukraine
are LED on this Mission by faith in God
Liberty and complete liberation
I'm not soft on Russia or anything
Russia is a geopolitical foe of the U.S
and I get it but with this kind of talk
coming out of the Ukraine military
with this kind of behavior coming out of
the Ukraine military are
we sure we're on the right side of this
thing is it is it possible that maybe we
we just in in the rush to pick a side
that are we sure that this is the right
thing to do I ask because the way that
this
person
is talking about the Russian devil
propagandists is pretty Broad
it's kind of the way that liberals in
the U.S will refer to anyone even
slightly to the right of Barack Obama as
a Nazi you say I'm not a Nazi I'm not a
racist I'm not a thisist I'm not a
phobic I'm not a this that but it
doesn't matter they just paint everyone
with that broad brush and I suspect here
this
person
the spokesman for the Ukrainian military
a YouTube spokesman is a gender-neutral
term I don't want to hear it don't take
me off
uh
it seems to be reacting to criticism
that he himself is getting so
I worry a little bit because I did a
long thread on this person a while ago
exposing a lot of bizarre aspects of
this person's biography and and how this
person managed to get to this position
in the Ukraine military so I don't know
am I going to be lumped in
with the Russian devils and the Russian
propagandists
I I think so I think that's the way this
spokesman is talking and that's not
great when they're threatening to hunt
everyone down
you know how we hear in the liberal West
that those autocratic regimes Russia and
China
they oppose journalism they oppose Free
Speech they oppose free expression
that's out of one side of their mouths
then out of the other side they say hey
anybody who criticizes Us in any way is
a Putin propagandist and and even if you
just use your words and even if you just
raise questions about the word we're
gonna hunt you down and kill you like a
rabid dog
that's what they say how do they do it
well because these people are on the
side of humanity they're not fighting an
ordinary War you see it's not just two
Powers two peoples with different
interests who are butting heads as has
happened throughout all of human history
no no no these people are fighting for
all of humanity
in fact we know that because this very
spokesman said that Russians are not
human beings
do you know the difference between us
and Them
besides fighting under this flag and for
freedom on behalf of the people of
Ukraine all the Russians are fighting
for tyranny and dictatorship
it's pretty simple
we're human
and those guys most definitely aren't
slavu crane
it's it's something out of Saturday
Night Live except it's real and this
person is speaking for uh the Ukrainian
military in the first major war in
Europe since World War II with a nuclear
reformer superpower and also with the
superpower of the world a nuclear power
as the belligerent using this proxy of
Ukraine in any case
anyone who opposes liberalism is not
just coming from a different point of
view not just coming from a different
Nation not just a different people not
just a different religion they're not
human according to these people
and so you see this this irony which is
that the people who fight
in the name of humanity in the name of
humanitarianism
are very often the most cruel
and wars that are fought in the name of
humanity
are going to be the least Humane Wars
that could possibly be fought
so you hear bubble gums and roses and
let's be inclusive and have
self-expression man and it's going to be
these people wearing their eccentric
outfits
with their unusual gender expression
they're going to be the ones who are
just happily inclusively diversely
sending all the big Bombs all the way to
their enemies
all right I think I managed to make it
around that discussion without getting
myself totally kicked off of YouTube
I said transvestite at the top they're
probably gonna have to believe that but
speaking of threats coming from Ukraine
our friend Vladimir zielinski leader of
Ukraine highest paid actor in the world
made 100 billion dollars last year
that's pretty impressive so that's
better than anything they're getting out
of Hollywood uh zelenski is threatening
the West Europe in particular if the
West stops funding the billions and
billions of dollars of Aid without which
Ukraine could not continue to fight the
war zelinski says quote
there is no way of predicting how the
millions of Ukrainian refugees in Europe
could countries would react to their
country being abandoned
I'm going to say that again without a
bad Ukrainian Accent on so you get the
threat that he's implying here there is
no way of predicting how the millions of
Ukrainian refugees in European countries
would react to their country being
abandoned
what does that mean well he says that
these refugees who have been given
Asylum by the generous countries of
Europe who are also funding this war for
Ukraine they have quote behaved well
so far
but their good behavior in in places
like Germany and France and Italy could
not be guaranteed necessarily to
continue and then he said it would not
be a good story for Europe if it were to
drive these people into a corner this
little pipsqueak mafioso is saying hey
Europe thanks for being the only reason
that our country is not a parking lot
right now hey Europe thanks for being
the only reason that that Vladimir Putin
hasn't given me a nice cup of polonium
tea up until now hey Europe thanks for
the billions of dollars and the Jets and
the guns and the ammunition oh and
taking all of our people in is refugees
um but hey if you don't keep it up we're
going to start killing you
that's what he's saying and in his
defense he's playing his hand very well
if I were the leader of Ukraine I would
be saying these exact same things this
guy is defending the interests of his
country and his people I don't really
have any problem with him doing that
that's how war and politics works
but why aren't the Western Europeans
defending the interests of their own
people and their own countries why is
the United States all too often not
protecting the interests of our people
and our country
why is that
can can we maybe start I don't know that
we can start doing that you're going to
hear the globalist type say
that actually funding the war in Ukraine
is one of the best military Investments
we can make because it's only something
like three to five percent of our
defense budget and we don't have to
sacrifice any American lives
and we'll just let the ukrainians and
the Russians kill each other
and that'll be good because it'll weaken
Russia
maybe I don't know that's a pretty
it's a pretty dangerous game to play
when you are accelerating a war with a
nuclear former superpower in a way that
Russia is saying the United States is a
belligerent in the war this is something
we avoided for the entirety of the Cold
War
including at that hot moment of the
Cuban Missile Crisis now we just seem to
be kind of sleepwalking into that war
meanwhile we open up the borders to
every to people from all around the
world including the ukrainians who
appear to be fairly dangerous now too
and meanwhile our supposed allies the
people that were funding they're the
ones who say yeah if you don't keep it
up if you don't keep the money coming
then we're going to murder you then then
I'm going to activate all of those sweet
wholesome refugees and we're going to
start causing a lot of trouble in Europe
and I think implicitly in the United
States as well are we really playing our
hand
or no are we committing a kind of
civilizational suicide
the likes of which Douglas Murray
predicted six years ago observed six
years ago and which since then has only
gotten worse I think we need an off-ramp
for this kind of Madness and speaking of
ramps you got to check out ramp
right now go to ramp.com Knowles are you
looking for a better way to simplify
your business finances across expenses
vendor payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a complete game changer
for your business ramp
is a corporate card and expense
management software designed to help you
save time and money with ramp you can
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to the time that you will save each
month on employee expenses will allow
you to close your books eight times
faster businesses that use Ram saving
average of 3.5 percent within the first
year ramp is easy to use get started in
less than 15 minutes whether you've got
five or five thousand employees right
now get 250 when you join ramp go to
ramp.com Knowles
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
apply
now turning to the home front here
turning to political leadership in the
United States
but Kevin McCarthy is pushing for an
impeachment inquiry into Joe Biden this
the Senate Republicans are not so happy
about this Mitch McConnell has not
really come out and supported this
actually no Republican in Congressional
leadership
uh certainly up in the Senate has come
out supporting this other than
Republican senator John barrasso
who came out and he said that the
corruption surrounding the Biden family
needs to be untangled according to
Punchbowl news bras who's the only
Republican in leadership who backed
McCarthy's efforts this is fine by me
this is a good sign that John barrasso
might be the man to take over after
cocaine Mitch has to leave cocaine Mitch
is not going to remain in leadership
forever
even despite the health scare is even
despite his Advanced age it's that's
just the way it works time goes on and
people are going to need to to come into
the wings I have said that I'm not for
pushing cocaine Mitch out just because
he had a couple brain freezes during
press conferences because one cocaine
Mitch has been pretty good at wielding
levers of power he's been especially
good on judges but three
who's going to replace him all the
prospects of people to replace cocaine
Mitch don't seem to be any better than
he is so while the conservatives might
be wailing and saying Mitch isn't one of
us he's establishment he's suppressing
our agenda that might all be true but
who's who's the replacement if we don't
have a better replacement then let's
just leave cocaine Mitch better the
devil we know than the devil we don't
if John barasso was going to come out
here and start flexing a little bit of
power start taking the side of the more
conservative wing of the conservative
party
that's a good sign the people who are
who are looking to replace cocaine Mitch
maybe they should get on board too
speaking of the Senate
Josh Hawley has just gotten in hot water
for proposing an 18 percent credit card
interest rate cap now this seems like
good news because we know these credit
card companies
prey on people they get them hooked on
debt especially people who don't have a
lot of money who are living maybe
paycheck to paycheck they'll start
putting big purchases on their credit
card and then because the the interest
rate is 18 or more 20 25 they're never
going to get out of that debt
so they're just going to be in debt
forever making these payments
and it's especially people who are at
the lower end of the socioeconomic
ladder who get squeezed this way now
10 years ago it would not have been a
conservative right-wing Senator
proposing an interest rate cap it would
have been Bernie Sanders and Bernie
Sanders would have given some speech
about the proletariat and the workers of
the world need to unite and those Rich
fat cut Millionaires and billionaires on
Wall Street they had taking advantage of
you workers and then uh Bernie Sanders
became a millionaire and then he stopped
inveying against the millionaires but in
any case it would have been a left-wing
attack and the conservatives would have
said well actually you know there's
nothing more American than usury
actually there's nothing more American
than taking advantage of poor people who
sometimes don't know any better and in
some cases don't have any other options
than to put their bills on their credit
cards and then get stuck in debt slavery
forever now things have flipped and as
Donald Trump and Ted Cruz have said the
Republican party has ceased to be the
party of Wall Street the Republican
party is now the party of Pittsburgh not
the party of Paris and this was a good
campaign line and it was a great way to
follow up the populism that that came to
the fore with the election of Donald
Trump but if that kind of populace
rhetoric and enthusiasm is not backed up
by hard policies then it's going to be
nothing it's going to ring Hollow so now
uh Josh Hawley is backing it up with
real hard policies
and he's doing this in particular
because he says
usury is bad
what is user user is lending money at
interest there's more to it than that
but for the vast majority of the history
of our country of our civilization
if we get our country it goes back much
further than that for the vast majority
of the history of our civilization
usury was against the law because of the
church prohibits it and it's not just
the church virtuous Pagan societies
prohibited usury as well other religious
Traditions uh ban usury as well why
but as Thomas Aquinas says to take usury
for money land is unjust in itself
because this is to sell what does not
exist and this evidently leads to
inequality which is contrary to Justice
in order to make this evident we must
observe that there are certain things
the use of which consists in their
consumption so he says we consume wine
when we use it for drink and we consume
wheat
when we use it for food
wherefore in such like things the use of
the thing must not be reckoned apart
from the thing itself and whoever is
granted the use of the thing is granted
the thing itself and for this reason to
lend things of this kind is to transfer
the ownership so that's a little bit
confusing but what Thomas Aquinas is
saying there is when you when you lend
money at interest when you when you
commit usury you are using the thing
twice you're double dipping basically
and that is not fair it says accordingly
if a man wanted to sell wine separately
from the use of wine he would be selling
the same thing twice or he would be
selling what does not exist wherefore he
would evidently commit a sin of
Injustice in like matter he commits an
injustice who lends wine or wheat and
asks for double payment
the return of the thing in equal measure
the other the price of use which is
called usury
we don't talk this way anymore because
our entire modern economic system is
based on usury and the loosening of laws
against usury has had
a material benefit the economy exploded
material wealth exploded that's all true
don't think that when you commit bad
things you don't receive at least
momentary or partial pleasure from it
you do of course you do if you didn't
then there would be no temptation to sin
if you didn't enjoy you know doing
naughty sex things you wouldn't be
tempted by them if you didn't get a a
sensory uh pleasure from eating too much
food or drinking too much booze there
wouldn't be a Temptation if all you got
was The Hangover you wouldn't want it
so there there are these
apparent benefits that come along with
vices and sins that's what tempts us
into them and with usury it's been the
creation of the modern economic system
which has given us a lot of material
wealth but are we so stupid in Liberal
modernity that we we think you can get
something for nothing do are we so
deluded in this utopian ideology that we
think there isn't a cost
to pretty much everything in this world
what's the cost
the cost is in this case that we've
indebted ourselves that we have become
individually and nationally
slaves to debt we've we've transformed
into a from a civilization that would
leave an inheritance to its children
that would leave the place better off
than we founded into a civilization that
in the words of the conservative writer
Patrick Deneen leaves to its children no
inheritance other than a mountain of
debt that is wrong there is a reason I
think we need to accept this in our
humility there is a reason that every
serious civilization ever
recognized that usury is very wrong
and you're not going to dismantle the
modern economic system maybe you don't
want to dismantle the modern economic
system
but we do have to acknowledge this is a
problem that a civilization that commits
this kind of a sin that indebts its
people this way that takes advantage of
people who sometimes aren't that bright
and who often don't have resources that
that's wrong to do
and that we haven't reinvented the moral
code
and that a civilization that prioritizes
material wealth above everything else is
a civilization that worships Mammon and
that is not going to be conducive to
human flourishing even if we get more
stuff
Senator Hawley I don't know what the
details are on this yet but he's going
down the right path also by the way it
is politically beneficial for
Republicans to be on the side of people
and not on the side of Wall Street jerks
so generally speak overall
this young upstart new right Senator
going down the right path speaking of
renewal you got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text Knowles to 200
300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
done before and for many it is not
something they want to do but rather
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive I have great
news you can now get a free in-home
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer service possible supported by
the best people in the industry a
superior process and an exclusive
product right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free in-home or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for one year text Knowles
Canada wies to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings won't last long so be sure
to check it out by texting Knowles Canon
wles to 200-300 that is Knowles Canada
wlie Esther 200 300 texting privacy
policy in terms of conditions posted at
textplan.us texting enrolls for
recurring automated text marketing
messages message and data rates may
apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details okay on the topic of debts and
deficits
big deficits now
turning on 2024 most Republicans have an
unfavorable view of Chris Christie
breaking news stop the presses Chris
Christie isn't very popular I know
that's not exactly a man bites dog story
this is according to morning consult
just one quarter of Republican voters
have a favorable view of Chris Christie
that gives him a net favorable rating of
negative 26. that's that's not great uh
who's the second least favorable
Republican that would be Mike Pence Mike
Pence has 37 percent of Republican
voters expressing an unfavorable view of
him his favorable rating however is
overall because unlike Christy 51
percent of people have a favorable view
of him so he's still doing way better
than Chris Christie is but he has a
pretty high on unfavorables too why do I
bring this up am I bringing this up
because I think there it goes Chris
Christie was this close to the White
House and then he disappeared
where Mike Pence was this close to
becoming the nominee no
I bring it up though because
Ron DeSantis I think still has a shot at
the Republican Party nomination and
these numbers do not bode very well for
him
because
in order for Ron DeSantis to become the
Republican Party nominee
Donald Trump either has to die
be ostracized
be legally prohibited prohibited from
running for president
or
Ron DeSantis has to persuade people to
stop liking Donald Trump Donald Trump
now has what a 50-point lead in the
Republican primary at least a 40-point
lead and even in the early primary
States it's a 20-point lead uh
DeSantis has to become much more
critical of trump
no one's going to do it for DeSantis so
DeSantis has to get much more aggressive
against Trump to try to knock down his
numbers but the problem with this poll
is what is the commonality between Mike
Pence and Chris Christie
the con there's not a lot that those
guys have in common but the commonality
is they are the two candidates who are
most critical and most openly critical
of Donald Trump
and you see what that gets them it gets
that gets them very very high
unfavorable rating and it gets them very
very low poll numbers in the Republican
Party
so I get why DeSantis is not being too
openly critical of trump
he can't be he sees what happens to the
other candidates who are openly critical
of trump but then what's the alternative
this is the the problem for his campaign
that has existed long before he
announced that he was running
he has very few options
for maneuvering where is he going to go
if he gets more anti-trump he's going to
end up like these two guys if he doesn't
hit Trump at all he's going to end up
like Ted Cruz in 2016 who was playing
nice with uh Trump until it was too late
so what's he gonna that's that's not a
knock on either of their campaigns I
think Senator Cruz ran a great campaign
in 2016 and it just it almost worked but
it didn't work and here you're seeing
the repeat of that same campaign and it
it hasn't gotten anywhere near close to
almost working as it did for Cruz in
2016. the question that the status
campaign has to ask now as it is caught
between a rock and a hard places
where can we go
and I I told you I'm not endorsing in
this primary I know a lot of
conservatives in the media and in public
life
are effectively working for these
campaigns I'm not doing it when DeSantis
does something good I'm happy to applaud
that and I do it almost every day when
Trump does something good and especially
if his campaign is doing well I will I'm
happy to point that out too when Vivek
is doing something away these guys are
are doing well I'm I merely want to
describe the campaign so I'm not working
for any of them and in the case of
desantis's problem what do you do when
you're caught between a rock and a hard
place I just don't have the answer if I
were working on his campaign I have no
idea what I would advise him to do right
now
it might be the case as you know I hate
to say I told you so but as I predicted
early on
that no matter how good a candidate
you've got no matter how genius the
Consultants are you hire the most big
brain people from Washington DC
sometimes the circumstances are such
that you don't have anywhere to move
putting people in a bad spot
brings my attention over to the view
where even one of the big Libs they're
all Libs on The View but one of the most
openly liberal people on The View Sunny
Hosten is finally willing to admit that
the bidens are dirty
people are going to be shocked I I
completely agree with that I think that
there has been some more shocking right
more though I I think that there has
been some impropriety I think that there
are instances when Hunter Biden in an
attempt to show access to the vice
presidency the vice president's office
made phone calls to Daddy those have
been taped I think we have the situation
uh with uh his work in Ukraine we have
the situation with his work in China
there's no way that political influence
wasn't a part of that I don't like
nepotism across the board I mean what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander and so I understand that there is
some real concern there but what is
upsetting to me is that Kevin McCarthy
and the Republican this right-wing
Republican party is trivializing what
impeachment is high crimes and
misdemeanors our former twice impeached
disgraced former president stuff accused
of
um you know talking to president
zielinski of Ukraine and trying to do a
quid pro quo and trade information for
arms when his country was about to start
or would go into war with Russia that's
pretty significant
that is literally what Biden did
it's she starts out well she says look I
think the bidens are a little dirty
they're peddling influence around the
world I'm willing to admit that but the
Republicans are trivializing impeachment
look when we impeach Trump we did that
because he pressured the leader of
Ukraine to give him something that he
wanted to benefit himself personally and
the threat behind that was that he would
withhold military aid as Russia was
looming in the border that is exactly
what Joe Biden did and Joe Biden
in his guileless corruption he actually
confessed to this at the Council on
Foreign Relations
they were walking out to Prescott said
no I said I'm not gonna or we're not
going to give you the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars I said you're
not getting a billion I'm going to be
leaving here and I think it was what six
hours I looked I said I'm leaving in six
hours if the prosecutor's not fired
you're not getting the money well son of
a
got fired you got fired the guy who was
investigating the company that was
sending my family a ton of money in
super super crooked payments that
prosecutor got fired because I told
Ukraine with an aggressive Russia
looming On the Border that I was going
to withhold a billion dollars in Aid
anyway dinner's on me tonight fellas
what bar do you want to go to
that this is so embarrassing for Sonny
Hosten on The View because she look she
made her bed she's gonna lie in it she
decided that she was going to
be a little bit honest about how corrupt
Biden is
even when some of the fake conservatives
on the panel were trying to continue to
carry water for Biden she thought that
she could engage in a limited Hangout
she thought that she could
give The Observers of Biden's corruption
just a little bit of Truth and say yeah
okay you're right but he didn't do like
what Trump did well we accused Trump of
doing when I guess Honey Austin just
doesn't follow the news closely enough
and the Democrats often unwittingly just
project the things that they accuse
their opponents of they themselves have
done she is describing and accusing
Trump of doing the thing that we have
video evidence of Joe Biden himself
doing sounds like Sunny Hosten and the
view is for impeachment
now
Senator Ted Cruz
unsurprisingly put this situation a
little bit more clearly and cogently
than the ladies of the view here is how
Senator Cruz
struck down one of the the biggest
talking points that the the libs are
relying on to stop the impeachment of
Joe Biden you know the latest talking
points Democrats are are trying to trot
out in response to this impeachment
inquiry is there is no direct evidence
of Joe's involvement in the corruption
so they've pretty much given up on
Hunter yeah Hunter's corrupt as the day
is long but there's no direct evidence
of Joe's involvement that's what they're
saying now that's a flat out lie too
there's at least two instances of direct
evidence of Joe's corruption number one
you played on this show which is Joe
Biden's admission in front of the
Council on Foreign Relations that he
held a billion dollars of U.S taxpayer
get loan guarantees hostage in order to
force the firing of the Ukrainian
prosecutor who was investigating the
Ukrainian oligarch that is one of the
critical elements of bribery of the quid
pro quo quid pro quo as you know is
Latin for this for that the that Joe
Biden has admitted to that is direct
evidence that he's admitted to the only
question is is there the quid is there
the five to ten million dollars of
payments now on that there is
circumstantial evidence there are the 20
million dollars plus of payments to the
Biden family and there is also the
consistent pattern of obstruction and
covering it up very well said of course
as usual and a point that the senator is
alluding to in this clip and he said
explicitly elsewhere is
circumstantial evidence is good enough
most of the time you'll sometimes hear
people say well you can't prove that he
committed that crime you've only got
circumstantial evidence
people are convicted of crimes every
single day in the United States on
circumstantial evidence circumstantial
evidence is pretty good circumstantial
evidence is different from direct
evidence and that direct evidence is hey
uh hey I saw it snow last night I I
stayed up late and I looked outside my
window and it was snowing and I saw that
and I took some pictures of it and I
video recorded it and there's the direct
evidence of the snow
circumstantial evidence is you go to
sleep and there's no snow on the ground
as Senator crew says and you wake up in
the morning and there's snow on the
ground and you say okay I don't have any
proof that it snowed I don't have any
hard direct proof that it snowed because
I don't have pictures or photographs I
didn't I don't have eyewitness testimony
but there wasn't snow on the ground when
I closed my eyes and there is snow on
the ground now so I am going to use that
circumstantial evidence to deduce it did
in fact snow
and we have got mountains of
circumstantial evidence that Joe Biden
engaged in this kind of corruption
handwritten notes text messages emails a
whole laptop from Hunter Biden giving a
real insight into these crimes and then
we've got some direct evidence as well
like when Joe Biden's admitting these
things at the Council on Foreign
Relations the only thing to do at this
point is to impeach if the Republicans
don't impeach we just look completely
feckless
so Senator Cruz is the right idea
Senator barrasso is the right idea and
the squishes need to get on board
speaking of corruption
moving from political corruption into
corruption in the Arts his videos just
gone viral
of
an intruder making it to some fashion
show where he walks down the runway
wearing a plastic bag before a security
guard stops him
there he is you guys got a shower cap on
he's got some kind of plastic bag or
Poncho and then he's strutting and then
finally a security guard takes him down
and the reason this is going viral I
don't know when this was shot I don't
know where this was shot but the reason
it's going viral is not because of the
the guy this was a good prank he pulled
it off well it's because the audience
looks completely non-blessed
so yeah there it is there's High fashion
and we all know this even if this were
just as sketch on in Saturday Night Live
or something we've all seen this happen
before where some Modern artists will
show something that's not beautiful
that's not particularly intricate that a
three-year-old could have put together
in two seconds and
because of the I don't know the
pretensions of the artist and of our
culture you'll have otherwise serious
you know well-dressed wealthy Elite
people looking at it trying to pretend
as though there's some deeper meaning or
that it's in some way aesthetically
pleasing how does this happen
this is what happens when art in a
society ceases to be connected to Beauty
we'll get to that in one second but
speaking of Art and criticism
[Music]
if you're not a member go to
dailywireplus.com subscribe to join
today
my favorite comment is waffles
mcgallagher 934 says the actress in the
Apple skit also portrayed God in a
Christian quote-unquote movie called The
Cabin weird how she portrays a deity
several different times it's because our
culture worships black women
and it's a little weird I like black
women in fact some of my best friends
are black women like my friend that I
was just talking about who made
convicting a murderer but I I don't
worship black women and our culture does
you see countless articles especially at
election time of oh black women have to
be Our Saviors again they're just so
they're the most perfect people on Earth
and they they're the most wise and
virtuous and and it's a kind of idolatry
probably a fetish of our culture it's
very very uh strange but that's why
that's why in Liberal portrayals God or
the Godlike figure is is often going to
be a black woman
and I say this as a swarthy man you know
there are lots of different categories
here
um but speaking of Aesthetics the reason
that this guy
was able to walk down the runway in a
plastic bag and have people take that
seriously as as high fashion is because
art
for at least 100 years now has not been
connected to Beauty any longer art has
become uh
critical uh self-referential ironic and
and really just a form of anti-art a
deconstruction of art you see this most
clearly with an artist like Marcel
Duchamp he's the modern artist who put a
urinal in the middle of the floor and
said this is a work of art the fountain
by the way I say this as a modern artist
I I don't want to toot my own horn here
folks I am one of the most prominent
modern artists in the world today my
modern art piece reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide
a number one best-selling blank book
that continues to sell oodles and
noodles of copies
that is a work of Modern Art that is a
deconstruction of the form of the book
and I yeah I'm a regular Marcel Duchamp
but I'm a regular Damien Hurst but
with all of those artists I get a kick
out of some of the work of like a Damien
Hurst who I mean he's got all these
weird works of art like a big shark and
formaldehyde or you know polka dots or
whatever or even martial Duchamp with
the urinal
but it's purely an intellectual and
critical Endeavor it's it's critical
it's not artistic it's not beautiful
when you disconnect from the
transcendentals
the good the true and the Beautiful You
are left in this morass of relativism
According to which you don't know if a
guy wearing a garbage bag is really
wearing high fashion and in that Society
because we we know that it's not
beautiful we're not attracted to it in
any way we just have to take our cues
from everybody else you kind of find
yourself looking around you is that
person taking the art seriously is that
person taking the art seriously
and then you convince yourself that ugly
works of art are actually beautiful and
worth lots of money
that's a society that's much more
volatile and I think it helps to explain
from the artistic angle some of the
political volatility that we're seeing
that was that was less common in earlier
ages of our country and our civilization
because we're not grounding our views
and our behaviors in anything objective
and real anymore the good that you're in
the beautiful are objective they're
unchanging we can discourse rationally
about them this kind of crap the modern
art and the wearing garbage bags around
and urinals pretending to be fine works
of sculpture
there's nothing objective about that
it's all socially contextualized it's
all contingent on the feelings of the
people in the room which can change
rapidly because man's passions are wild
and the imagination of man's heart is
evil from the beginning
spect more volatility the more crazy
kooky art we get
speaking of Art
is this one going to kick me off YouTube
too or I'm gonna try I'm gonna try to
speak in a very specific way here and
you can either blame me I don't know
we'll see what happens
the actress
[Music]
now speaking of things that men and
women do together there's a new study
out
very helpful to the pro-life cause and
very helpful to poor little babies who
are being targeted by liberals uh
it knocks down a lie that we've heard
which is that abortion is not painful to
babies abortion is not painful to babies
at a certain point it becomes painful
and when the when the babies are capable
of pain then maybe we'll have some
restrictions on it but early on in
pregnancy it's just not painful to just
we can poison them and chop them up and
they don't feel any pain and that's
obviously not true and I think we all
know intuitively that's not true well
we've got a study now that backs it up
it's called reconsidering fetal pain
by two medical professionals Stuart
Derbyshire and John C Bachmann
uh what the study says is fetal pain has
long been a contentious issue
in large porpius fetal pain is often
cited as a reason to restrict access to
termination of pregnancy or abortion
very clinical language but he says we
have Divergent views regarding the
morality of abortion but have come
together to address the evidence for
fetal pain so they're saying look we
don't we're not both pro-lifers we're
not both pro-abortion we have different
views on abortion but we're just
addressing do these babies actually feel
pain and they say at 12 weeks gestation
there were the first projections from
the thalamus into the cortical subplate
and then they use a bunch of scientific
jargon to explain how we think that pain
begins much much later in pregnancy but
actually no it doesn't as people think
now begin around 24 weeks it probably
starts around 12 weeks gestation
and so what the conclusion is fetal
analgesia and anesthesia should thus be
standard for abortions in the second
trimester especially after 18 weeks when
there is good evidence for a functional
connection from the periphery into the
brain so this is an amazing conclusion
what they're saying is look
we used to think there was pain starting
at 24 weeks that the babies would feel
the pain now we think it could be as
early as 12 weeks and it certainly as
early as 18 weeks so when you murder
your baby at 12 to 24 weeks give them an
anesthetic
and then chop him up or poison him or
inject him full of saline solution but
but when you're about to murder your
child just know he's in excruciating
pain so you're going to want to give him
an anesthetic before you chop him up
um
what what woman
maybe some psychopath doctor you know
doctor abortionist doesn't care about
any of that but what mother is going to
say wait my baby feels pain
so okay if I'm gonna have to give him an
anesthetic so I can kill him well if I
give him anesthetic he sounds kind of
like a person
because people feel pain so it doesn't
feel just like a clump of cells anymore
maybe I shouldn't kill my kid
now what's amazing here is the
fact of whether or not a baby in the
womb feels pain should not be all that
morally relevant
there are people who can't feel pain
they're still people they we still
shouldn't murder them the question is is
this baby a baby is this a human being
is this a live person
one of the uh aspects of being a living
person is that you feel pain often and
much of the time you are capable of
feeling pain but that shouldn't actually
matter to the moral question of whether
or not it's right to kill an innocent
little baby whether he feels pain or not
and yet it is relevant politically it is
relevant because as a friend of mine
says facts don't care about your
feelings but politics I will complicate
the phrasing politics largely cares
about your feelings
and the science here is on our side and
the science doesn't just exist in a
vacuum
our bodies don't just exist in a vacuum
the facts of this world don't exist in a
vacuum the physical facts of this world
imply certain metaphysical things and
moral things and they pull on our
heartstrings for good reason and this is
all the more reason for the
conservatives as we get a new generation
of leadership and we stop being so
squishy to get even tougher on these
laws and stand up for objective truth so
we don't live in a subjectivist
relativistic civilization where we've
got urinals all over the floors
pretending to be art the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it this is a really big show my
friend Congressman Eric Burleson is
going to be on the show
uh Congressman Burleson is on the alien
committee the UFO committee and you know
my views on the aliens but just
yesterday we had that big breaking news
story that
some obvious hoax artist made a little
statue of E.T and pretended it's a
thousand-year-old alien mummy so anyway
we'll get to that latest update and we
will destroy Matthew Walsh with facts
and logic a use code Knowles right now
dailywire.com
use code and also checkup for two months
free on all annual plans be right back
[Music]